like its predecessors Dark Souls 3 can
be dense and there isn't much
hand-holding if you play Demon Souls
Dark Souls Dark Souls 2 or even
blood-borne did you know what I'm
talking about
but if Dark Souls 3 is your first taste
in the punishing RPG series there are
certain things you should probably know
before you begin your grueling adventure
exploration is the key to success sure
it can be frightening but the rewards
almost always outweigh the risks an
alternate path can lead to a shortcut
new weapons armor souls rings undead
bone shards Estus shards and the list
goes on even if you've defeated the boss
in an area it's always worth your time
to backtrack and pick up something you
may have missed
dying in Dark Souls is normal as I'm
sure you've heard plenty of times but if
you're hardly doing any damage to
enemies in a given area it's probably
time to hightail it out of there chances
are you've stumbled into an area that
you aren't quite ready for yet backtrack
and see if you missed an alternate route
believe it or not reading an item
description can be really important in a
Souls game not only do they provide
insight into the world but they can also
lead you in the direction of new quests
valuable items in secret areas item
descriptions are especially important
when it comes to keys in most cases the
description will tell you exactly where
you should stick that key speaking of
providing insight into the world you
should also speak to every NPC multiple
times keep talking to them until they've
started repeating themselves similar to
item descriptions NPCs will guide you to
secret areas give you items and in Dark
Souls 3 chatting up certain NPCs can
also get you different endings this one
should come as a no brainer but if you
neglect the blacksmith you're gonna have
a bad time the blacksmith can expand and
reallocate your Estus flasks add status
effects to your weapons and most
importantly reinforce them as you
collect titanite shards or chunks visit
this guy that kind of looks like a
jacked Santa Claus in the Firelink
shrine and he'll reinforce your weapons
typically he won't charge that many
souls either so it's usually worth your
time if you've been playing a lot of
blood-borne leading up to Dark Souls 3
you'll probably be doing a lot of
rolling and if you're equip load is high
your roll will be slower and clunkier
and it will take longer for your stamina
to recharge as you equip armor and
weapons be sure to keep an eye on your
equip load which you can find right up
here
by now you've probably noticed all the
orange messages scrawled across the
ground just from this video alone if you
play Dark Souls before you know exactly
what they are but if not it's worth
knowing more about these messages these
notes are usually left by other players
and you should be worried about trusting
some of these some can be really helpful
while others can lead you to your death
if a message is sitting at the edge of a
cliff that says treasure below I
probably wouldn't recommend walking off
to sea usually you can gauge how
trustworthy one of these messages are by
seeing how many appraisals it has before
you pop one of those hefty bottles wait
after you defeated the first few bosses
visit this decrepit old fart on the
throne and chat him up basically you can
trade these souls for one of two unique
items keep in mind that you can only
pick one per playthrough for each of the
souls you collect
I like to think of co-op as a last
resort in Dark Souls after a few dozen
failed attempts then it might be time to
consider phoning in some help hosting a
co-op game is pretty easy as long as
you're logged into the servers you might
notice some summon signs on the ground
all you have to do is examine it and
voila someone will come to your aid if
you want to help someone else out then
you're gonna need an item called white
sine soapstone and it's important to
note that you will only match make with
someone who is around the same level as
you and the bosses tend to get a little
bit tougher when you have someone by
your side it's also important to note
that both parties need to be m bird in
order to participate in a co-op game
hopefully these tips will come in handy
if Dark Souls 3 is your first in this
series if you're already a Dark Souls
pro leave some of your tips in the
comments below and for more on Dark
Souls stay tuned to game spot
you